sell your daughter for five horses and
almost throw your disabled son off a
cliff
because we have the most badass show
about barbarians since
crush your enemies see them driven
before you
and they hear the lamentation of their
women netflix's barbarians is based off
the true story of the battle of tutaburg
forest in 9 a.d in which the vastly
outnumbered germanic tribes defeated the
romans so in this video we're going to
be going back in time
taking a deep dive into history and
explaining some of the show's hidden
details
and what it could mean for season two
but before we begin make sure to like
and subscribe as i'm always coming out
with new videos
the last episode starts with a betrayal
segestus a former reich or
leader of the german cheruskin tribe has
figured out that gaius julius armenius a
prefect of the roman cavalry and adopted
son of the roman governor
is planning to betray the roman army and
lure them into a trap
you see armenius and his brother were
taken from their family as young boys
and raised by
varys as romans they were considered a
peace offering between the germanic
peoples and the romans and it's when he
arrives back in germania
he becomes a man trapped between two
worlds does he side with the barbarians
his blood
or the romans the ones who raised him
and it's this struggle that weighs on
him throughout the series
ultimately siding with the barbarians
after witnessing the innumerable
atrocities committed by the romans these
include taking away the tribe's last
remaining
food murder and crucifixion while these
are terrible
acts it's also armenius's lack of
freedom that spurs him to change sides
it's this theme of freedom versus
destiny that drives at the core of
barbarians armenias entire life has been
controlled by
others specifically his adopted father
governor varys who even makes him the
reich of the cherusky in an effort to
solidify
roman hold in the region barbara penato
says
has been nothing but a pawn of rome his
entire life
his job as a soldier is literally to
follow orders he
has no autonomy in this way he can
empathize with the barbarians
both are subject to the will of others
both have no freedom
in a bit of irony varus says to
armenians max
gloria costata
but armenius can't choose his own end
it's chosen for him
unless he takes matters into his own
hands joins the barbarians and fights
for freedom this line about being able
to choose your own end also foreshadows
varys
death he chooses his own end by taking
his life something that actually
happened when he realized he'd lost the
battle i also want to take a moment to
mention armenius's brother
flavis the show kinda glosses over what
happened to him but if we follow history
he'll play a major role in
upcoming seasons unlike armenius flavis
was loyal to the romans fighting
alongside the great roman general
germanicus
not to be confused with the germanic
tribes against his own brother at the
battle of wesser river a battle that was
sparked after armenius found out his
wife and child
were captured by the romans so this
could mean next season we see thus nelda
getting captured with their child or
should i say fulquin's child and we'll
get into that a bit later in the video
so back to the main story seguestus
exposing armenius as a traitor was
motivated by his lust for power
armenia said taken away his daughter and
his role as reich
if he could prove his loyalty to varys
he could have both of these things
back even if it comes at the betrayal of
his own people
but armenius is smart and confesses
telling varys that it's true
he plans to take on the giant roman army
of
15 000 men with a small group of 500
warriors and that the real fulquin the
person he was supposed to kill a few
episodes ago
is working as a slave in the roman camp
it's a story that's so
outlandish varus can't help but to laugh
and this really ties into rome's
greatest weakness the belief that
they're invincible
although they are outnumbered arminius
plans to exploit this belief of
invincibility
by splitting the army up in the forest
and launching an ambush
think of it as a giant snake hacked into
smaller more manageable parts
but the peace between the germanic
tribes is frail before the battle is to
take place hadkin
reich of the chattan bows out after this
nilda denies him she was promised to him
by sagestus as his bride
to unite their tribes but he's a piece
of [ __ ] and this nelda is now married to
armenius a marriage that started as one
of convenience
a way for armenius to gain the trust of
the tribe since he's still considered
a roman outsider with hadkins men no
longer in the fight the other reichs bow
out but it's up to thessnelda who they
believe is a seer handpicked by the gods
to rally them for much of the season
this nilda has had a strange
relationship with the gods
often calling on them for help and
sacrificing her blood in the process
she claims to have dreams which predict
the future and she tells the men that
she's seen the outcome of the battle
a glorious victory over the romans but
to really
prove to the men she means business she
cuts her eyes
sacrificing it like their god wolten did
to his own eye to see the future now
it's never really explained whether her
eyesight in this eye is gone for good
she wears an eye patch during the battle
but later when talking to armenia she
says she's fine so we'll have to put a
pin in that one for now
this idea of sacrificing to the gods has
major implications for next season
as falquin promises his firstborn child
in exchange for the power to defeat
varys in one of the biggest reveals of
the episode runa the oracle
tells thus nelda that she's been with
child for some time
and the father isn't who she thinks it
is meaning the father is likely
fulquin and not her husband armenius and
with fulquin having promised his
firstborn child
things could get really messy the first
part of the battle begins in the forest
where the stretched out romans are
easily picked apart and separated by
falling trees
armenius takes off his helmet showing
his barbarian war paint
and for a brief moment he is reunited
with the snelda he doesn't tell her that
her true love fulquin is still alive
having been captured as a slave by the
romans but that will come into play
a bit later on the romans retreat back
into the open where the barbarians have
prepared a trap of flames
separating them further and from this
point it's a massacre as the romans are
caught off guard and picked off one by
one
i should also mention sagestus's
alliance with haddon offering him his
daughter
should the romans be victorious and
sigestus himself will become the new
reich they end up joining the battle
later on when it's clear the barbarians
will win
but the show is really setting up new
rivalries and alliances for next season
you may have also noticed ansgar thus
nelda's disabled brother in the middle
of the battle
earlier in the season runes said that
ansgar was spared because the gods still
have a plan for him
insinuating that his presence on the
battlefield is somehow linked to the
rain this rain
made it much more difficult for the
roman soldiers to fight in the mud due
to their heavy armor
in comparison to the lightly armored
barbarians it's a similar strategy the
english incorporated against the french
in the battle of agent court and if you
haven't checked out my video on the king
you totally should
varus seeing has he's led his men to
their own deaths a result of his hubris
kills himself ironically with arminius's
knighthood sword which was given to him
in part because of his loyalty i'm not
sure if they were trying to make him
more sympathetic here but right before
he does he freezes slave paleguios
it's also kind of ironic that varus
spent much of the season putting other
people's heads on spikes
and ends up on one himself with the
romans defeated and the barbarians
victorious the snelda and armenius
reunite
she understands what armenius must be
going through and how his father used
him
and believe it or not festelda isn't too
upset that armenius didn't tell her
about fulquin
this is largely in part because she's
fallen in love with armenius she will
continue to be his queen she'll later
talk to fulquin who says to come to her
once she's made her decision
on who to be with but it's clear she's
already made up her mind the snelda
fulquin and armenius used to be great
childhood friends but
this relationship has changed everything
when armenius asks fulquin to be his
first lord fulquin responds
that is sees her father's augustus but
doesn't say a word with him it's her
chat with runa and the discovery of her
baby that really set things up for
season two
she believes this child especially that
it's not armenia's
could be punishment from the gods the
snelda has lied about her dreams the
ones supposedly given to her by the gods
in order to sway her people to her will
and the gods might not think too kindly
to that ari is visited by a wolf
something he's been visited by
countless times over the season in fact
the first episode is called the eagle
and the wolf this symbolism here is open
to interpretation much like how it's
described in the show the barbarians
believe wolves symbolize destruction
while the romans believe the wolf
symbolizes life and creation
as it was a wolf that saved romulus and
remus as young boys
the eventual founders of rome so it's
really up to us whether we want to
interpret this as a hopeful sign or a
deathly omen finally we have the last
scene of the season which sees
a cloaked figure taking varys head past
the corpses of the defeated roman
army the important thing here is not so
much who this cloaked figure is
but where they're going my guess is rome
to pass on the news of what was at the
time
rome's most catastrophic defeat the
romans would eventually send one of its
greatest generals germanicus adopted son
of emperor tiberius
to take on armenius and it's kind of
interesting that both these leaders were
adopted as children
as i said earlier if there's a season 2
it will likely pit armenius against his
own brother
who fights alongside germanicus this
results in the battle of wesser river a
huge defeat for the germanic tribes and
one in which armenius is severely
wounded but evades capture
but i want to hear what you thought
about barbarians thanks for watching
everyone
please make sure to like subscribe and
share and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much